-Lacey!
-Hi!
-Welcome to the show.
-Oh, my goodness.
Thank you so much for having me.
-I'm so psyched
to have you here.
We just had -- Lindsay Lohan
was just on the show.
-Yes.
-And we were talking about
"Mean Girls."
And we showed --
Yeah, we showed a picture of --
[ Cheers and applause ]
The "Jingle Bell Rock" scene.
-My goodness.
-Would you ever do
a "Mean Girls" reboot?
-Oh, absolutely.
I think it --
[ Cheers and applause ]
-You would?
You'd have to, right?
-I mean, I think it would be
so much fun to see
where these women are now
and if their kids
are the new mean girls.
-Yeah.
-You know?
I would love to know
what they're doing.
-Tina, if you're watching,
yeah, let's do it, yeah.
Do people always
come up to you and go,
"You can't make fetch happen."
-Yes.
Every day of my life.
-Every day of your life, really?
Everyone knows --
They go --
-Yes, everyone's like,
"Oh, that's so fetch."
I was even sick recently
and picking up a prescription,
and the pharmacist goes,
"Oh, you look like you don't
feel very fetch today."
[ Laughter ]
-I have to say --
they say you're
Queen of the Christmas
Hallmark movies.
And you really are fantastic
in these movies, by the way.
How many have you done?
-I've done 33 for Hallmark now.
-I've seen all of them.
-Have you really?
And you are fantastic.
-You're so kind.
You know what?
Do you want to be in one?
I have some stuff next year.
Like, I would love to be
in one with you.
-Yes! I would love to be in a
Hallmark -- are you kidding me?
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yes!
Let's make this happen.
-Let's do it.
Why not?
-Everything is --
Why do you think
people love it so much?
Is it just 'cause it makes
you happy, or what is it?
-I think, now more than ever,
like, we just need
some goodness in the world.
And it's like people sit down
in their living rooms
for two hours.
They give you their time.
And they're
left feeling uplifted.
-Yeah.
-And, you know, it's joyful.
That's why I love
being a part of them.
And people come up to me all the
time, and they go, "You know,
it's my husband and I,
it's our favorite thing
to do together.
This movie has helped
bring my family together,
the tradition of watching them."
So I consider it an honor
to be a part of.
-I watch them with my dad.
-You do?
-Yeah, he likes them, too.
-I love that.
-I watch them with my wife, too.
And I watch them by myself.
I just love -- I'm obsessed.
I'm obsessed.
-Thank you so much.
-But how do you do 33?
What's the schedule like?
-Oh, my word.
Okay. So the schedule
is fast and furious.
We do them in 15 days,
and it's --
-Wow.
-Yeah. It's really long days.
And sometimes they air, like,
two months after we filmed it.
-But are you
all over around the world?
Are you in Italy?
Are you in --
-Yes. Oftentimes, we are.
-Wow.
-I've been to Belgium.
I did one in South Africa.
That was amazing.
We were staying on the reserve
where we were filming.
And, I mean, you'd have
to peek out the door
to make sure the giraffe wasn't
right in front of your door.
It was magical.
-Really?
-Everything that
my character discovered
in that movie was really me.
I didn't have to act.
-"The Wedding Veil" trilogy.
This is three of the
most-watched Hallmark movies
of all time, starring you.
I'm a fan of that.
I think I got word
to your people.
Just say, "Hey, by the way,
I'm loving it right now.
Don't spoil it.
I want to watch
the whole trilogy."
-Thank you so much.
-But you have an announcement
to make for any fans.
-Yes, Autumn Reeser
and Ali Sweeney and I,
we are gonna be back with
three more "Wedding Veils."
We're currently filming them.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Come on!
-Yeah.
We're currently filming
the last one.
We're about to actually
head to Greece this weekend
to film the third one.
But Ali is the lead-in.
And we are so excited to bring
these characters back to life.
Because the movies
always end with a kiss,
they fall in love.
And now we get to see
what happened after that.
There might be babies,
the friendships are deeper.
And so, January 7th,
the first one is premiering.
-Congrats on that.
[ Applause ]
Can we talk about
your new Christmas project?
-Absolutely.
-This is "Haul Out the Holly."
Can you tell everyone
what this one's about?
-Well, my character goes home
hoping to just relax
and be home for Christmas
and watch Christmas movies
and do nothing Christmas-related
in the neighborhood.
'Cause where she's from,
the HOA department
of the cul-de-sac is, like,
crazy about Christmas.
-Yeah.
-They go all-out.
She gets, you know,
pulled into the activities.
And this is the first time
I've done a Christmas movie
that's a comedy.
-Yeah.
-It's a wonderful cast.
Melissa Peterman, Wes Brown,
Stephen Tobolowsky,
Ellen Travolta.
These amazing people that just
made me laugh all day.
-And you get to do some physical
comedy, which I do love.
I'm a fan.
I want to show everyone a clip.
Here's Lacey Chabert
in "Haul Out the Holly."
Take a look at this.
-I was wondering
when you'd like to meet
to plan the snowman parade.
-Right.
Uh, how about later tonight?
-No.
No.
I never plan anything
after the cookie contest.
-Oh, okay.
Why not?
-If I lose, I'll be
in no condition to do anything.
-Good for you for being honest.
-But I've never lost.
-Right, no, of course.
Okay.
So, uh, if you win --
-"If"?
If I win?
-Sorry, sorry, sorry.
No, I mean, when --
-Okay, don't jinx me.
-Right.
-Just --
-Please. Mmm.
-There you go.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Lacey Chabert,
"Haul Out the Holly"
premieres this Saturday
at 8:00 p.m.
on Hallmark Channel.
We'll be right back
with more "Tonight Show."
Stick around, everybody!